they spoke CEO Mark Zuckerberg will give
testimony to three congressional
committees and two hearings this week it
will address how Facebook's user data
was improperly accessed by Cambridge
analytic ah the consulting firm used the
information for politically targeted
advertising during the 2016 presidential
election around 87 million Facebook
users had their information mine this
all comes as Facebook suspended another
data analytics firm cube U for allegedly
collecting user data improperly Facebook
only took action after a news outlet
alerted the company Cube you told CBS
News in a statement qmu takes great care
to collect data in compliance with all
relevant privacy provisions and laws
Sandeep Eric Ellis led the team at
Facebook responsible for data privacy
violations on the company's app platform
he says he warned Facebook in 2012 about
potential risks like the Cambridge
analytic a scandal sandy good morning
good morning thanks for having me on
what sandy do you want to hear Mark
Zuckerberg say right away at the hearing
to prove that something different there
well I think the first thing he needs to
do is he needs to address the the
corporate governance of Facebook he is
unaccountable at the moment he controls
the company 100% and so it's not a good
situation to have someone who has that
much power over a company of this much
importance you say he's unaccountable
but he's on the hook right now and being
talked about every second he's gone in
front of Congress and they've just lost
millions of dollars on the market so of
course that's a lot of pressure on him
he seems pretty accountable well it's a
lot of pressure but keep in mind no one
can fire him there's no independent
board that can step in and say hey mark
you're not doing a good enough job we
need you to step aside that's so
specifically about the privacy concerns
that you warned Facebook about explain
essentially how these outside apps got
access to our information yeah so it's
important to remember that apps on
Facebook when you use them they ask you
for permission to access specific kinds
of data you know whether it's your name
or your email address or your friend
lists or photos or other information and
once you once you click allow
tap allow all that information passes
from Facebook to the application
developer and the problem is that once
the data goes to the developer
there's no insight into what the
developer is doing with the data and
there's no control by Facebook as to
what they do it you know this has been a
known problem since they allow all these
apps to have access to our private data
yeah it's a good question and the reason
that they wanted to do that to begin
with is they wanted developers to build
really rich full-featured applications
that were social for the platform
well that would then help Facebook make
money yes we when you left in 2012 did
you leave on good terms because I'm
trying to determine is this a case of
sour grapes on your part that listen I
told you guys because you have now been
gone for the company from the company
for quite some time
yeah so I I did and I went and worked
for a company that was doing Facebook
advertising working it closely in
partnership with Facebook for for two
years after so you know I continued to
work with the company and I continue to
believe in the company it's only
recently that I've started to become
really concerned about some of the
implications of what this data can be
used for what's new is that there are
companies like Cambridge analytical that
are able to use this data to understand
and predict how you're going to vote
they can predict your personality type
that's why they wanted this data from
Facebook and they built all these models
according to Chris Wylie who's the the
whistleblower at that at Cambridge in
Helvetica well they're building all
these models that can predict your
behavior and then they can use that
information to go back into Facebook and
buy ads that that target you and try to
manipulate you based on your personality
and your voting preference well facebook
says they they have taken steps to
prevent this from happening again
including banning app developers who
don't agree to audits making privacy
tools easier to find and showing users
how to revoke data permissions is that
enough well they've taken some steps to
address some of the most the most
obvious concerns here I think that
frankly the way the platform was built
to begin with wasn't built with the
safety of users in
and that's a huge problem they could
have built it in a much different way
where they they you know they had a much
more limited set of features and they
controlled the data and they just
allowed developers to access you know
modules that would let you sit friends
what did you think when you spoke it
when you were there do you think you
could have done more do you do you take
any responsibility if you saw this Sandi
coming do you think that you should have
shouted a little louder I probably could
have done more to be totally Frank like
I know I saw some of the risks coming
and you know other people at the company
obviously understood this risk as well
did you tell mark and Cheryl
specifically I don't remember having a
specific conversation with a marker show
but this but you know this was well
known at the company there there was a
Wall Street Journal article in 2010
about this issue about a company called
wrapped leaf that was taking application
data you personally identifiable data
from Facebook and passing it or we're
getting that information and then
selling it to ad networks so when you
heard the breach you thought what I
thought oh no like this is this is this
is something that they've known about
that I've known about that I tried to
raise some alarm about and now it's
being used for a really devastating
purpose all right sandy parochial is I
think people are listening we're
listening thank you very me too